So that's going to be what we'll cover for
the Primitive types before we dive into our
project
And now we'll actually go into making our
And today we're going to be building out
together The Adventures of the code Works
Crusader
and today we're going to be building out the
adventures of the code Works crusader
I'm going to show it off really quick
So once this project is finished we'll
create this interactive game it'sOn where we
were at.
Once we finish this project we're going to
have this interactive gameA click game I
want to say click game.
After our project is finished we have this
interactive clicking game so the purpose of
this game is we're going to create some
JavaScript for whenever I click on this
What's going on
?
I typed clear
into the
wrong spot
So once we're finished with the project
we'll have this interactive clicking game
All right one more time let's take it from
the top
After we finish this project we'll have this
interactive clicking game application
And when I select this attack button you'll
notice both of our health go down and
we're going to be building this out using
JavaScript and connecting that to our
indexWill also hopefully.
If we will give ourselves a random chance to
actually spawn in a potion to find a potion
and when
we do find that potion we're going to create
something where we can actually see that
potion pop up
And then we're going to create this button
here to actually add Health to our pool
And right now it's set up on an interval so
you can see it took a little bit of time so
let me try to get another potion
If I click this right now it's set up on a
three second intervalAnd then we get that
Health there.
We're also going to show off the get element
by ID and that's how we're going to input
these images here
I'm going to use a lot of arrays
Actually use a race I take that back
We're going to mainly create a lot of
functions it's going to add functionality to
our web page
Yeah I think I already kind of said it
though didn't I
So we'll be incorporating
a lot of the
information we just
went over for
our primitive types
into this project
And I look forward to building this
alongside you guysI don't like that last
part.
And let's go ahead and get into building out
the codeworks CrusaderBam Bam Bam.